[Music]
hello
[Applause]
it's a shock in japan it's very
difficult for individual japanese to
get hold of weapons it's something that
japan has very rarely experienced shinzo
abe was campaigning in a national
election that's taking place on sunday
for parliament's upper house
then an assailant stepped forward and
apparently
shot mr abby
[Music]
[Applause]
shinzo abe was through a number of
changes to japan's economy and also its
military
situation he promoted the alliance with
the u.s he was a close uh
ally of particularly former president
trump and
promoted cooperation between the u.s and
japanese militaries that had been
difficult previously so he's certainly
by any estimation
one of the most influential
prime ministers and leaders in japan's
post-war history